When Anne met Charles, they were not supposed to fall in love. It was forbidden that they fall in love. Capulets and Montagues, Jets and Sharks, David Addison and Mattie Hayes on Moonlighting, Scully and Mulder, Anna Karenina, you know the story. The day they met, she was a nurse in the Texas prisons. He was a prisoner, support service inmate. First day on her new assignment, working in the infirmary.
当安妮遇见查尔斯时，他们本不该坠入爱河。他们被禁止相爱。凯普莱特家族与蒙太古家族，《喷气机》与《鲨鱼》，《蓝色月光》里的大卫·艾迪森与麦蒂·海斯，斯卡利与穆德，安娜·卡列尼娜，你知道这些故事。他们相遇的那天，她是德州监狱的一名护士。他是一名囚犯，也就是后勤劳役犯。在她新工作的第一天，她在医务室上班。
They're called SSIs, which is a janitor service there. And there was four new ones came in that day. And they come bebopping down through the hall and started to the back of the infirmary. And I ask them just where they thought they were going. He says, "Honey, you did take my head off a time or two that day." So that was the first time I'd ever seen him.
他们被称为SSI，也就是那里的清洁工。那天来了四个新人。他们大摇大摆地走进大厅，开始往医务室后面走。我问他们以为自己要去哪儿。他说：“亲爱的，你那天可是凶了我一两次啊。”所以那是第一次见到他。
Was this the kind of thing where the first time you looked at him, you thought, "Huh, wonder who that is."
这属于那种你第一次看他时，心里想“哼，不知道那是谁”的情况吗？
No, no.
不，不是。
She'd see him around, mopping, clearing out trash. And then, as always happens in these kinds of stories, fate threw them together, together in a situation where it was the two of them against the world.
她常看见他走来走去，拖地、清理垃圾。然后，就像这类故事里常发生的那样，命运让他们走到了一起，在一种两人对抗全世界的情况下。
We worked together for a couple of months and then got into a situation that involved some real sticky stuff that I'd really rather not get real specific about. But he told me some information about some stuff that had taken place while I was out of the infirmary one evening. By the time I got through facing off people, it brought a lot of heat on both of us.
我们一起工作了几个月，然后陷入了一个涉及一些棘手问题的处境，我宁愿不具体说明。但他告诉我一些关于我那天晚上不在医务室时发生的事情的信息。等我应付完那些人时，这给我们就招来了很多麻烦。
And did the two of you actually blow the whistle on somebody in a way that officers got disciplined and punished?
你们俩真的举报了某人，导致官员受到了纪律处分和惩罚吗？
We blew the whistle, yes. The officer got a promotion instead of getting disciplined. They basically totally isolated us both, because I took the word of an inmate over that of an officer. And they don't like that.
我们举报了，是的。那个官员非但没有受罚，反而升职了。他们基本上把我们俩彻底隔离了，因为我采信了一个囚犯的话，而不是官员的话。他们不喜欢那样。
And nobody talked to the two of you? And so did that mean that you ended up having a lot of time alone with each other?
没有人跟你们俩说话吗？这意味着你们最终有很多时间单独相处？
Well, it ended up being we were the only two to talk to. We talked to each other. And I really got to know what kind of a person that he was, and that he will stand up for truth when other people will skirt around it. But he will face what's coming down, just so that the truth comes out, at great personal risk to him.
嗯，结果就是我们成了唯一能交谈的两个人。我们交谈。我真正了解了他是一个怎样的人，他会在别人回避真相时挺身而出。但他会直面即将发生的一切，只为了真相大白，哪怕冒着巨大的个人风险。
Still, his crime?
那，他的罪行是什么？
He was in for murder. He killed a man that raped his niece. And he's been given 25 years for that.
他因谋杀入狱。他杀了一个强奸他侄女的男人。为此他被判了25年。
It's drilled in our head all the time. Anyone that works there, it's drilled in your head that these people are out to con you. They're going to pull something on you. They're going to blackmail you into doing something. This is the prison system's way of looking at things.
这种观念一直灌输在我们的脑子里。任何在那里工作的人，都被灌输这些囚犯一心想骗你。他们会设圈套害你。他们会勒索你做某事。这就是监狱系统看待事物的方式。
But not everyone that's inside the prison system is that way. That was one of my major problems, is I could not understand, and I could not treat them like they were animals. I just couldn't do it.
但并不是所有在监狱系统里的人都是那样的。这是我的主要问题之一，我无法理解，也无法像对待动物一样对待他们。我就是做不到。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today in our program, for Valentine's Day, stories of forbidden love.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，我是《这美国生活》的艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的情人节节目中，我们讲述禁忌之恋的故事。
Act One, Meet the Ball and Chain. What happens when you fall in love with somebody who you're supposed to treat like an animal? Act Two, Mucho Corazon. What happens when you fall for somebody that your country, your entire country, does not want you to live with? Act Three, a story of impossible love to end all stories of impossible love, or 1,001 one of them, anyway. Stay with us.
第一幕，认识“枷锁”。当你爱上一个本应像对待动物一样对待的人时会发生什么？第二幕，深情厚谊。当你爱上一个你的国家，你的整个国家，都不想让你和他在一起的人时会发生什么？第三幕，一个终结所有不可能爱情故事的爱情故事，或者至少是1001个故事中的一个。请继续收听。
Act One, Meet the Ball and Chain. When Anne Staggs started to fall for an inmate named Charles in the Texas prison system, she was up against odds as daunting as they ever get for two people. It was against the rules, possibly dangerous. Certainly, it could put her job on the line.
第一幕，认识“枷锁”。当安妮·斯塔格开始爱上德州监狱系统里的一名囚犯查尔斯时，她面临的阻碍对两个人来说是极大的挑战。这违反规定，可能很危险。当然，这可能会让她丢掉饭碗。
They were never alone. They could never say anything in front of other people. And he was, not to put too fine a point on this, a convicted murderer.
他们从不独处。他们永远不能在别人面前说话。而且他是一个——别怪我说话太直——被定罪的杀人犯。
You know, in any relationship, there's some moment where somebody says to the other person, "I'm having these feelings." When was that moment between the two of you, and where did it happen?
你知道，在任何一段关系中，总会有某个时刻，一个人对另一个人说：“我有这种感觉。”你们俩之间的那个时刻是什么时候，发生在什么地方？
In the infirmary. I had been putting my medications on the computer, charting. And he came in. We'd been talking quite a bit that day.
在医务室。我当时在电脑上输入药物信息，做记录。他进来了。那天我们聊得很多。
Anyway, he came in and said something to me. And I turned around and looked at him. And I said, "I love you." And he looked me right square in the eye. And he says, "No, you don't."
总之，他进来对我说了一些话。我转过身看着他。我说：“我爱你。”他直视我的眼睛。他说：“不，你不爱。”
And I told him, I said, "Don't you ever, ever tell me I don't love you." I said, "I didn't say I was in love with you. I said I loved you."
我告诉他，我说：“别再对我说我不爱你。”我说：“我没说我爱上了你，我说的是我爱你。”
And it took him a while to accept that, because he was of the opinion at that time that he didn't think he was worthy of being loved. And about two days later, he came back and told me that he loved me, too. I was sitting in the nurse's station with my head down, charting, when he walked in there.
他花了一段时间才接受这一点，因为他当时认为自己不值得被爱。大约两天后，他回来告诉我，他也爱我。我当时坐在护士站，低着头记录，他走了进来。
And I looked up and said, "Hi." And he looked at me. He said, "Hello." And I went back to charting. And he said, "I love you." And I said, "Thank you."
我抬头说：“嗨。”他看着我。他说：“你好。”我又回去做记录。他说：“我爱你。”我说：“谢谢。”
Wow. How very businesslike.
哇。真是公事公办啊。
Well, under the circumstances, with other people all around, it kind of had to be.
嗯，在这种情况下，周围到处都是人，只能这样了。
How much time was it between him saying that he loved you and you actually kissing?
从他说他爱你到你们真正接吻，过了多久？
About a month.
大约一个月。
And if you're willing, I mean, I don't mean to pry too much if you don't want to talk about this. But what were the circumstances of you actually kissing the first time?
如果可以的话，我是说，如果不想谈这些我也不会深究。但你们第一次接吻的具体情况是怎样的？
At 5 o'clock every day, we give the insulin to the diabetics.
每天5点，我们给糖尿病患者注射胰岛素。
How romantic.
多浪漫啊。
No, that's not romantic. And someone had stuck their size 14 foot right in the middle of the sheet on the gurney. And I mean there was a big footprint right there. And I hollered at him and asked him to come change the sheet on the gurney. And while he was changing the sheet on the gurney is when I took the opportunity to kiss him. And I was the one that instigated it.
不，那不浪漫。有人把他们14码的大脚丫直接印在了病床的床单中间。我是说那里有个巨大的脚印。我冲他大喊，叫他来换病床床单。就在他换床单的时候，我抓住了机会吻了他。我是主动的那一个。
Was he surprised?
他惊讶吗？
Yes. He seemed very surprised.
是的。他显得非常惊讶。
So how'd it go?
那感觉如何？
Wonderful. Very, very, very sweet. I would love to be able to put my arms around him right now.
太棒了。非常非常非常甜蜜。我现在真想能搂住他。
It progressed from there. Other than the hugs and the kisses, there was never any other sexual activity, period. There just couldn't be. That's just absolutely the way it was. It just couldn't be.
此后进展顺利。除了拥抱和亲吻，没有发生过任何其他性行为。根本不可能。事情就是这样。就是没法发生。
It sounds like you were in a situation where there's no possibility of privacy at all.
听起来你们处在一个根本没有任何隐私的环境中。
If we got a minute to talk by ourselves, that was unusual.
如果我们能有一分钟单独谈话的时间，那都算罕见的。
When was the next turning point in your feelings? When did you understand that things had gone to another level?
你们感情的下一个转折点是什么时候？你什么时候意识到事情上升到了另一个层面？
It was about the 1st of February. We were standing in the exam room, talking about something. He was cleaning and I was doing something else. And this blond guard walked in, who had never been in the infirmary unless she had to be, come in and asked for a cup of coffee. He always kept a big pot of coffee going in the back.
大约是2月1日。我们站在检查室里聊着什么。他在打扫，我在做别的事。那个金发警卫走了进来，她如果不是必须来，从不进医务室，她进来要一杯咖啡。他在后面总是备着一大壶咖啡。
And when he left the room with her to get her a cup of coffee, I could have just easily pulled her head off and told God she died. And that's when I realized I was in way over my head, and there was no denying the fact that I was in love with him. It had gotten to the point that I knew that we would eventually be discovered, simply because I really had a problem staying away from him. And the security staff watches you like hawks. So it was inevitable.
当他和她离开房间去给她拿咖啡时，我当时简直想直接冲过去把她宰了。就在那一刻，我意识到我陷得太深了，无法否认我爱上了他。事情发展到这一步，我知道我们迟早会被发现，因为我确实无法远离他。保安人员像老鹰一样盯着你。所以这是不可避免的。
Do you think it makes it more intense, the fact that your feelings were forbidden for each other?
你认为你们之间的感情被禁止，这会让它变得更强烈吗？
Oh, definitely. You can talk to any woman or any inmate that has developed a relationship under the circumstances that ours was developed. And they will tell you beyond belief that the intensity of the relationship and the intensity of the feelings is far beyond anything that we've ever experienced before. I know several of the women that are married to inmates, and they'll tell you the same thing.
哦，肯定的。你可以去问任何在那种环境下发展出关系的女性或囚犯。他们会告诉你，这种关系的强度和情感的强度远远超过我们以前经历过的任何事情。我认识几个嫁给囚犯的女性，她们也会告诉你同样的事情。
Now you've been married before too, yeah?
你以前也结过婚，对吧？
Yes. I was married for 26 years.
是的。我结婚了26年。
And this is more intense than--
这比那段婚姻更强烈——
Oh, yes. I have discovered that I never knew what being in love was.
哦，是的。我发现我以前从不知道什么是坠入爱河。
Do you worry that your feelings are still idealized because you just haven't had the time to spend with each other alone?
你是否担心你们的感情是因为缺乏独处时间而被理想化了？
To a point, yes. There's going to be a lot of adjustments to be done whenever we finally get to be together.
某种程度上是的。当我们最终能在一起时，还有很多需要适应的地方。
And so what happened next?
那么后来发生了什么？
On February 23, a guard came in. And he and I were standing back by the refrigerator fussing. He was getting ready to go back to his cell. And it was a few minutes until I got off work. And we were talking and cutting up.
2月23日，一名警卫进来了。我和他当时站在冰箱后面闹着玩。他正准备回牢房。离我下班还有几分钟。我们当时正聊着天，开着玩笑。
And she reported that she had caught us kissing, which she did not. That don't mean I hadn't kissed him. At that point, she did not catch us kissing, OK?
她报告说抓到我们接吻，其实并没有。这不代表我没吻过他。但在那一点上，她并没有抓到我们接吻，明白吗？
And a little while later, after he went to his cell, the lieutenant brought him back to the infirmary to do his PHD physical, which was a Pre-Hearing Detention physical. Which means he's in big trouble. And I asked him what they were bringing him down there for, and they said that he was under investigation.
不久之后，在他回牢房后，中尉把他带回医务室做PHD体检，也就是“听证前拘留”体检。这意味着他有大麻烦了。我问他们带他来这儿干什么，他们说他在接受调查。
And I did his physical. And I kept telling him, I'm sorry. I knew whenever she came in and looked at us the way she did that she was going to report us. And I kept telling him I was very sorry that it was coming down, because I knew that it was really going to be bad on him.
我给他做了体检。我一直在跟他说，我很抱歉。当她进来用那种眼神看我们时，我就知道她会举报我们。我一直在告诉他，我很抱歉事情演变成这样，因为我知道这对他的处境非常不利。
Wait a second. Let me be sure I've got this right. So he's about to get punished for kissing you and being close to you. And the first part of the punishment is that he's sent to you to be physically examined?
等一下。让我确认一下我没听错。所以他因为吻你、与你亲近而即将受到惩罚。而惩罚的第一部分是他被送到你这里进行体检？
Yes.
是的。
Does this not strike you as being kind of an odd thing, that he's about to be punished essentially for the two of you touching, and the first moment of the punishment is he's sent to you alone for you to--
这不让你觉得很奇怪吗？他因为你们俩的接触而即将受到惩罚，而惩罚的第一刻就是他被单独送到你这里，让你——
Oh, he wasn't alone. The lieutenant was with him and sneering the whole time.
哦，他不是单独一人。中尉和他在一起，全程都在冷笑。
Oh, OK. Understood.
哦，好的。了解了。
I was allowed to leave the unit that night. Then I was called back onto the unit about 10 o'clock the next morning. And I spent a couple hours in interrogation with the internal affairs people.
那天晚上我被允许离开单位。第二天上午10点左右我被叫回了单位。我和内务部的人进行了几个小时的审讯。
What'd they ask and what'd you tell them?
他们问了什么，你又告诉了他们什么？
There was a lot of questions. They ask about the sexual activity, which there was none. They ask if I had been bringing contraband in to him, which there was none. They wanted me to tell them every sordid detail. And I was not real cooperative in that area.
问题很多。他们问及性行为，根本没有。他们问我是否给他带过违禁品，也没有。他们要我告诉他们每一个肮脏的细节。在那方面我不太配合。
Do they even ask you about your feelings for him in that situation?
在这种情况下，他们问过你对他有什么感觉吗？
Yes, they did.
是的，他们问了。
They do. How exactly do they ask? Do they actually ask the question, "Do you love him?"
确实。他们具体是怎么问的？他们真的问了“你爱他吗？”这个问题吗？
Yes.
是的。
And did you admit to loving him?
你承认爱他了吗？
Yes. Yes, and then they insisted that I write my resignation.
是的。是的，然后他们坚持要我写辞职信。
Did you get a chance to say goodbye to him?
你有机会跟他告别吗？
No.
没有。
They gave him a year on medium custody. And they put him in the fields to work.
他们判了他一年中级监禁。他们把他派到田里去劳动。
Now when they were talking to him and interrogating him, internal affairs had told him that after it was all over with, and after everything calmed down, that he would be able to put me on his visiting list and I would be able to see him. He put me on his visiting list in September. And my birthday's in October, so he wrote and told me that I could come see him the week after my birthday. When I went in to see him, they would not let me see him at all. One of the officers there recognized me and told me that I could not visit with him. They stopped him, gave him a major case. And he started his one year over again in medium custody. So he was actually on medium custody for 19 months.
现在，当他们对他进行审讯时，内务部告诉他，等一切结束，一切平息后，他就能把我列入探视名单，我就能去见他。他在九月份把我列入了名单。我的生日在十月，所以他写信告诉我，我可以去见他。当我进去见他时，他们根本不让我见他。那里的一名官员认出了我，告诉我不准探视。他们阻止了他，并给了他一个重大违规处分。他一年中级监禁的刑期重新开始计算。所以他实际上被中级监禁了19个月。
So you didn't even see him for a moment?
所以你连见他一面都没有？
No. No, they never let him out of the building to come to the visitation area.
没有。没有，他们从未让他离开大楼去探视区。
What rule was he violating at that point? You were no longer a prison employee.
那时他违反了什么规定？你已经不是监狱雇员了。
One of the officers lied and said that they had given him a direct order for him not to put me on his visiting list. They wrote him a major case on disobeying a direct order. And my husband had never gotten a case before, had never been in any problems, no disciplinary problems before. And it still hurts my pride.
其中一名官员撒谎说，他们曾直接下令让他不要把我放在探视名单上。他们以违抗直接命令为由给了他一个重大违规处分。我丈夫以前从未违规，从未惹过麻烦，没有纪律问题。这至今仍刺痛着我的自尊。
The next letter that I got from him, of course, he was really upset because they had stopped the visit. And then in the very next letter, he asked me to marry him. He said he had wanted to do that at visitation. But since they are not going to let us visit, that he wanted me to marry him right then.
我从他那里收到的下一封信里，他当然非常难过，因为他们阻止了探视。然后在下一封信里，他向我求婚了。他说他本来想在探视时这么做的。但既然他们不让我们探视，他就想让我现在就嫁给他。
And were you surprised?
你感到惊讶吗？
Yes. The fact is when I was reading the letter, I went to crying. I was very, very happy at that point. And a girlfriend of mine who was already married to an inmate was there with me. And she kind of got upset, because she thought there was something else desperately wrong. Whenever I told her that he had asked me to marry him, she says, "Well, are you going on?" I said "Well, of course."
是的。事实上，我在读那封信时，哭了。当时我非常非常高兴。我的一位已经嫁给囚犯的朋友当时和我在一起。她有点不安，因为她以为出了什么严重的差错。当我告诉她他向我求婚时，她说：“那，你会答应吗？”我说：“当然。”
How does it work? Does he basically just sign something, and you sign something, and then you're married?
这怎么操作？他基本上只要签个字，你签个字，然后就结婚了？
No. He sent me what is called a proxy paper out, saying that he intentionally asked me to marry him, that he wants to marry me. And there's some other stuff on it. And then I have to take that and his identification papers and obtain the marriage license.
不。他给我寄了一份所谓的代理委托书，说他是有意向我求婚，他想娶我。上面还有其他一些内容。然后我必须拿着这个和他的身份证件去申请结婚证。
And you know that we got married right here on the radio station. And my deal about doing it that way is I wanted my husband present at our wedding. And that was the only way that that was going to happen.
你知道我们是在广播电台结婚的。我决定这样做是因为我想让我的丈夫出席我们的婚礼。那是唯一能实现这一点的办法。
So then the marriage takes place on the Prison Show on KPFT in Houston. And the host of the show, Ray Hill, stands in as proxy for Charles, who's still in his cell somewhere.
所以婚礼是在休斯敦KPFT电台的“监狱秀”上举行的。节目的主持人雷·希尔代表依然在牢房里的查尔斯担任代理人。
My name is [? M. O. Johnson. ?] I'm pastor at Rose of Sharon Baptist Church. And I am glad to be on this program to do this wedding. I told Sister Anne that this is the right thing to do.
我叫M·O·约翰逊。我是莎伦玫瑰浸信会教堂的牧师。我很高兴参加这个节目来主持这场婚礼。我告诉安妮姐妹，这是正确的做法。
It was fantastic. At that point in my life, you could not have told me that this was not the most beautiful cathedral in the city of Houston.
太棒了。在我生命中的那个时刻，你不可能说服我这里不是休斯敦城里最美丽的教堂。
Well, now, let us start the ceremony. Brother Stagg, this is for you. Wilt thou have this woman to thy wedded wife, to live together after God's holy ordinance, in the holy state of matrimony? Wilt thou love her, comfort her, honor her, and keep her, in sickness and in health, for as long as ye both shall live?
那么，让我们开始仪式。斯塔格兄弟，这是对你说的。你是否愿意娶这位女士为妻，根据上帝神圣的条例共同生活，进入神圣的婚姻状态？你是否愿意爱她、安慰她、尊敬她，无论疾病还是健康，至死不渝？
For Charles, by proxy, I do.
代表查尔斯，我愿意。
Amen.
阿门。
And what did you hear from your husband? He wrote you and told you that he heard the wedding show.
你从你丈夫那里听到了什么？他写信告诉你他听到了婚礼节目吗？
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
What did he say about it?
他对此怎么说？
He repeated his vows right along with Ray.
他跟着雷一起重申了他的誓言。
That's what he did when he was listening?
他听的时候就是这么做的？
Yes. And he was as thrilled with it as I was.
是的。他和我一样激动。
Now, Sister Anne, wilt thou have this man to thy wedded husband in the holy state of matrimony for as long as ye both shall live?
现在，安妮姐妹，你是否愿意嫁给这位男士为夫，进入神圣的婚姻状态，至死不渝？
I do.
我愿意。
Amen. We will ask my brother to place this ring on Sister Anne's hand. And, my brother, you repeat this. As a pledge--
阿门。我们请我的兄弟把这枚戒指戴在安妮姐妹手上。我的兄弟，你跟着说。作为一种誓约——
As a pledge--
作为一种誓约——
--and in token of these vows--
——并作为这些誓言的象征——
--between us made--
——在我们之间所作——
It's such a strange thing to listen to, him taking the vow in proxy.
听着他通过代理人宣誓真是件奇怪的事。
It was.
确实是。
--the Holy Ghost. Amen.
——圣灵。阿门。
Amen.
阿门。
Amen. Those whom God hath joined together, let no man put asunder. Let us pray.
阿门。上帝所配合的，人不可分开。让我们祈祷。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
It's also strange to hear a wedding ceremony where there's nobody there to kiss at the end.
听一场最后没有人可以亲吻的婚礼仪式也很奇怪。
That part kind of got me. But I'm going to make up for it when he comes home. I promise you.
那部分确实让我有点感触。但我向你保证，等他回家时我会弥补这一点的。
I just have a message for Charles. Sweetheart, I love you very much. I can't promise you that I'll be around for the rest of your life. But I can promise you that I will love you for the rest of mine. And I just thank God that he brought us together. Thank you.
我只想给查尔斯带个话。亲爱的，我非常爱你。我不能承诺你我会陪你走完余生。但我可以承诺你，我会爱你直到我生命的尽头。我感谢上帝让我们走到了一起。谢谢。
Thank you, Anne.
谢谢你，安妮。
Are you worried that it's going to be different when he's out, and when you actually get a chance to be together?
你是否担心当他出来，当你们真正有机会在一起时，一切会变得不同？
Sometimes, the fear of the unknown. But I know that our love will overcome all of it.
有时会，害怕未知。但我知道我们的爱会克服这一切。
It's so strange. It's a fear of the unknown with somebody who now you've been married to for quite a while.
真奇怪。明明结婚已经有一段时间了，却依然害怕未知。
Yeah, we've been married a year now.
是啊，我们已经结婚一年了。
That's right. You've had an anniversary.
没错。你们已经度过了一个周年纪念。
The 5th of December, we were married one year. And that's been one of the happiest years of my life.
12月5日，我们结婚满一年了。那是我一生中最快乐的一年之一。
Even though they're married, Anne and Charles are still not allowed to see each other or speak on the telephone, because he's not been allowed to put her, still, on his official visitors list. At the time of our interview, he still had to serve between one and five years of his sentence.
尽管他们已经结婚，安妮和查尔斯仍然不被允许见面或通电话，因为他至今仍没被允许把她列入正式探视名单。在我们采访时，他还需要服刑一到五年。
[MUSIC - "CONCRETE AND BARBED WIRE" BY LUCINDA WILLIAMS]
[音乐 - 露辛达·威廉姆斯的《混凝土与铁丝网》]
Coming up, other stories to hopefully break your heart for this Valentine's Day, in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，在国际公共广播电台节目继续后的几分钟里，还有更多希望能让你心碎的情人节故事。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, for Valentine's Day, impossible loves. Stories of people kept apart who think that they should be together. We have arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Mucho Corazon.
这里是《这美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选定一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的情人节节目主题是：不可能的爱情。讲述那些被迫分开但认为自己应该在一起的人们的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，深情厚谊。
In any love story, there always has to be some thing, some moment, some device to bring the two people together. And this next story begins with a man in Amsterdam, Leon Perlee, and a woman in Cuba named Milades Sosa. And what brings them together from such different worlds is an instrument, a musical instrument. That's all it takes, my friend.
在任何爱情故事中，总得有某种东西、某个时刻、某种方式让两人走到一起。下一个故事始于阿姆斯特丹的莱昂·珀利和古巴的一位名叫米拉德斯·索萨的女性。将这两个来自不同世界的人联系在一起的是一件乐器，一件乐器。仅此而已，我的朋友。
The instrument in this particular case is a street organ, an antique street organ, big and made of wood. It doesn't have a keyboard or anything. You crank a handle and it works like a player piano, blowing air through holes in these long cardboard sheets. Leon has a small workshop in Amsterdam where he restores these. It's how he makes a living.
这个特殊情况下的乐器是一架街头风琴，一种巨大的木制古董街头风琴。它没有键盘什么的。你摇动手柄，它就像自动钢琴一样工作，通过这些长长的硬纸板上的孔吹气。莱昂在阿姆斯特丹有一个专门修复这些风琴的小作坊。这就是他谋生的手段。
It has to be punched with holes in a certain pattern. When a hole in the book passes over one of the keys, the key will jump up in the hole. And the note in the organ, which is connected with this particular key, will start to sound. And then the pipes will start to speak. OK, let's start the organ.
必须按照特定的模式冲孔。当书册上的孔经过其中一个键时，键就会跳进孔里。连接在这个键上的风琴音符就会开始发声。然后管子就开始奏鸣了。好了，让我们启动风琴。
[MUSIC PLAYING - STREET ORGAN]
[音乐播放 - 街头风琴]
In Europe today, these hand-cranked organs are ancient history. But as it turns out, a century ago, these European machines crossed the Atlantic. And these days, in Cuba, a street organ factory is still in operation, a factory caught in a bubble in time, still turning out these instruments. Naturally, Leon had to go see it for himself three years ago.
在今天的欧洲，这些手摇风琴已是历史古董。但事实证明，一个世纪前，这些欧洲机器曾跨越大西洋。如今，在古巴，一家街头风琴工厂仍在运营，这家工厂像被困在时光泡泡里，依然在生产这些乐器。理所当然，莱昂三年前不得不亲自去看看。
So I was standing at Guarda la Vaca beach, white sands, blue sea, blue sky, people in swimming suits and bikinis. Yeah, it's very nice. And there was a big open-air tent. And there was an organ with a battery of percussions next to it, five people playing conga, bongo, timbales. And people were so impressed by it because it was just like a real orchestra which was playing. And it was marvelous.
所以我站在瓜达拉瓦卡海滩，白沙、蓝海、蓝天，人们穿着泳装和比基尼。是的，非常美。那里有一个巨大的露天帐篷。旁边有一架带有打击乐器的风琴，五个人在演奏康加鼓、邦戈鼓、天巴尔鼓。人们对此印象深刻，因为它就像一个真正的乐团在演奏。真是太奇妙了。
Well, my uncle, the one who works in the organ factory, told me that there was a group from Holland that was going to be at the factory. They were interested in organs. And they were going to have a party for those persons. He invited me to go there, but I was a little afraid. I didn't dare to talk to any foreigner.
嗯，我叔叔，那个在风琴工厂工作的人，告诉我有一个来自荷兰的团体要来工厂。他们对风琴很感兴趣。他们要为这些人举办一个派对。他邀请我一起去，但我有点害怕。我不敢和任何外国人说话。
And then I think he said I could help translate. And he insisted. And I didn't want to be unpolite. And I went with him to the factory.
后来我想他说是让我帮忙翻译。他坚持要我去。我不想显得没礼貌。我就和他一起去了工厂。
I am sitting on a table with my uncle, having fun, drinking. And then all of a sudden, I see a big man, white skin. Ah, that look in his face, like a child. I felt my heart start to beat faster.
我和叔叔坐在桌边，玩得很开心，喝着酒。突然间，我看到一个大个子，白皮肤。啊，他脸上的那个表情，像个孩子。我感觉自己的心跳加速了。
There came a man towards me. And he tried to start a conversation. But he found out that my Spanish was just as good as his English. He asked me to wait. And he came back with a young lady with sunglasses on, and it came out that she was his niece.
一个男人朝我走来。他试图开始交谈。但他发现我的西班牙语和他英语水平差不多。他让我等一下。他带回了一位戴着太阳镜的年轻女士，原来她是他的侄女。
I took my glasses off. So I'm looking into his eyes. Something was happening in him. It's the same that is happening inside me. I could see it in his eyes.
我摘下了眼镜。我盯着他的眼睛看。他内心发生了什么。和我内心发生的一样。我能从他的眼睛里看出来。
From the first moment she took off her glasses, I felt like coming home. Everything fell in its place. My soul was complete.
她摘下眼镜的那一刻，我就感觉回到了家。一切都归位了。我的灵魂完整了。
It was just love at first sight.
那真是一见钟情。
I just knew I was in love.
我只是知道我坠入爱河了。
We were talking. It was so nice talking. It was like if I had known him my whole life. It was great.
我们在聊天。谈话真的很愉快。就好像我认识他一辈子了。太棒了。
I was forced to leave there, because we had to be on time at the airport. So I tried to extend the time of leaving as long as possible, but they were calling me [INAUDIBLE]. "Come on, Perlee, we have to go. The airplane is waiting."
我被迫离开那里，因为我们必须准时到达机场。所以我尽量延长离开的时间，但他们一直在叫我，“快点，珀利，我们得走了。飞机在等。”
"Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's okay. I'm coming."
“是，是，是。没问题。我来了。”
Five minutes later, "Perlee, come on, now. We have to go."
五分钟后，“珀利，快点。我们得走了。”
I saw the car leaving, and he was looking back and saying, "Goodbye."
我看着车开走，他回过头说：“再见。”
I hoped she would write me. But it was still unexpected. And I was happy about it. Because I hoped it was not just something which lasted one day, at least not from my feelings. I was sure about my case, but of course, you never can look into the soul of another person.
我希望她会写信给我。但这依然很意外。我对此很高兴。因为我希望这不仅仅是一天的事情，至少从我的感情来说。我对自己很确定，但当然，你永远无法看透另一个人的灵魂。
"Cuba, August 31, 1995. Dear Perlee, first of all, my most sincere greetings for you and my wishes of prosperity. Before beginning this letter, I will tell you that I have missed you as if I would have met you since my childhood. Referring to me, I am 21 years old. I study at the training teachers college. So I will be a teacher soon. I enjoy dancing, reading, having new friends, traveling here in Cuba.
“古巴，1995年8月31日。亲爱的珀利，首先，向你致以我最诚挚的问候，祝你一切顺利。在写这封信之前，我要告诉你，我思念你，就好像我从小就认识你一样。关于我自己，我今年21岁。我在师范学院学习。所以我很快就会成为一名教师。我喜欢跳舞、阅读、结交新朋友、在古巴旅游。”
It will be very nice to hear about you and your country. I know that in spite of being a small country, it's nice. Besides that, there is produced a delicious butter.
“听听关于你和你国家的事会很棒。我知道虽然这是一个小国，但它很美。此外，那里还出产美味的黄油。”
My friend, you are not going to believe that I keep the postcard you gave me in a place where I can take a glance at it every time. It really brings good memories. Take care of yourself and write soon. Kisses, sincerely, Milades."
“我的朋友，你不会相信我把你给我的明信片放在一个我每次都能看一眼的地方。它确实带来了美好的回忆。保重自己，尽快回信。吻你，诚挚地，米拉德斯。”
So I hoped for it, and well-- this is something which you can touch. You can read it again. That was one of the best moments in my life.
所以我期待着，嗯——这是你可以触摸的东西。你可以反复阅读。那是我一生中最美好的时刻之一。
"Dear Milades, thanks for the nice letter. I received your letter the 10th of October. There is something on its way for you. Hope you like it. Love and kisses, Leon."
“亲爱的米拉德斯，谢谢你的来信。我在10月10日收到了你的信。有东西在寄给你的路上了。希望你喜欢。爱你的，莱昂。”
And when he said there is something on its way for you, he meant Mucho Corazon. This is a music book he arranged with love for me. And the first page, you can see how he dedicated, wrote for me, that is, "From Leon, with love." It was in September, '95. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
当他说有东西在寄给你的路上时，他指的是《深情厚谊》。这是一本他为我整理的充满爱意的音乐书。在第一页，你可以看到他是怎么献给我的，写的是，“来自莱昂，满怀爱意。”那是95年9月。
The rest is just a piece of cardboard full of holes. He can't really take it. And I didn't know what to do with it. I don't have an organ. I have to go to the factory. This is the tune.
其余的只是一块满是孔洞的纸板。他真的拿不走。我不知道该怎么处理它。我没有风琴。我得去工厂。这就是那首曲子。
[MUSIC - "MUCHO CORAZON" ON STREET ORGAN]
[音乐 - 街头风琴版《深情厚谊》]
These are the words to "Mucho Corazon."
这就是《深情厚谊》的歌词。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
"I don't need a reason to love you, because my heart is so big."
“我不需要理由爱你，因为我的心如此宽广。”
[MUSIC - "MUCHO CORAZON" ON STREET ORGAN]
[音乐 - 街头风琴版《深情厚谊》]
"September 23, 1995. Dear Leon, it was so nice to learn that you have not forgotten me. In fact, I was afraid about it."
“1995年9月23日。亲爱的莱昂，得知你没有忘记我真是太好了。实际上，我一直很害怕。”
"Amsterdam, 20 September, 1995. Dear Milades, before opening your letter, I had to calm down myself because my heart was beating like crazy. And as I read it, it gave me a very warm and good feeling inside."
“阿姆斯特丹，1995年9月20日。亲爱的米拉德斯，打开你的信之前，我不得不让自己冷静下来，因为我的心脏跳得快疯了。读着它，内心有一种非常温暖和美妙的感觉。”
"To be sincere, I have read it more than six times today. And now I decided to write back to you. Believing that you think of me, too, was one of the best things that could have happened to me."
“老实说，我今天已经读了六遍了。现在我决定回信给你。相信你也想着我，是我能经历的最美好的事情之一。”
"Dear, dear, Milades, would you believe me as I told you that every night before I go to sleep, and in the mornings when I arise, I kiss your name on the letter? So you have to write back very soon, because it's wearing out very rapidly."
“亲爱的，亲爱的米拉德斯，如果我告诉你每天睡觉前，早上醒来时，我都会亲吻信上你的名字，你会相信吗？所以你必须尽快回信，因为它磨损得很快。”
"Can you imagine how I would feel if you came here again? Please, if possible, do it as soon as you can. It'll be great. Kisses, Milades."
“你能想象如果你再来这里我会是什么感觉吗？求你，如果可能的话，尽快过来。那会很棒。吻你，米拉德斯。”
"A thousand kisses."
“一千个吻。”
[MUSIC - "MUCHO CORAZON" ON STREET ORGAN]
[音乐 - 街头风琴版《深情厚谊》]
The second time I went to [INAUDIBLE] was December 1995.
我第二次去古巴是在1995年12月。
I was scared because I didn't know what to expect from a man who lives in a developed country. I didn't know what he could expect from a girl from a small city in a poor country.
我很害怕，因为我不知道该从一个生活在发达国家的男人那里期待什么。我不知道他会从一个穷国小城市的女孩那里期待什么。
I was really nervous.
我真的很紧张。
We didn't know anything about each other. It was just some letters.
我们对彼此一无所知。只是些信件。
It sounds stupid. But I was really nervous to meet her again.
这听起来很蠢。但我再次见到她时真的很紧张。
I went to the airport. I saw him.
我去机场接他。我看见了他。
I walked towards them. And Milades, she laid her hands on the window. And I put my hands also against the window. And I was laughing, because I have quite big hands, and her hands are rather small. It looked as if there was a baby hand laying in my hand.
我朝他们走去。米拉德斯把手放在窗户上。我也把手放在窗户上。我笑了，因为我的手很大，而她的手相当小。看起来就像一只婴儿的手放在我手里。
He was taken. Oh, his body was taken. I could feel it when he took me in his arms.
他被抓住了。哦，他的身体被抓住了。当他拥抱我时，我能感觉到。
I tried to give her a kiss in the taxi. But even that didn't work. She was just like a shy bird.
我试图在出租车里吻她。但甚至那都没成功。她就像一只害羞的小鸟。
I was voiceless. I couldn't say a word. He tried, but he was also nervous.
我失声了。我一个字也说不出来。他尝试了，但他也很紧张。
They took me to my house. And I told my mother, "Oh, mama, I'm dying. I don't know what's happening." It was something completely new. What I was feeling, since I met him, I couldn't explain it.
他们带我去了我家。我对妈妈说：“噢，妈妈，我要死了。我不知道发生了什么。”那是全新的东西。自从见到他，我那种感觉，我无法解释。
I couldn't sleep that night. And I was afraid also, because many girls were going out with foreigners for money. That was not my case, but I was afraid he and the rest of the people could think that.
那天晚上我睡不着。我也很害怕，因为很多女孩为了钱和外国人出去。那不是我的情况，但我害怕他和其余的人会那样想。
At one particular night, we went out together, I think some drinks at some bars.
有一天晚上，我们一起出去，我想是在酒吧喝了点酒。
We were going hand by hand, talking. We had had a nice night. There was a couple behind us. And it was a young man with a girl. And he said, "Tu [BLEEP] [BLEEP] conmigo? Yo compro." It's, have sex with him, and he will buy it.
我们牵着手在走，在交谈。我们度过了一个美好的夜晚。后面有一对情侣。是一个年轻人带着一个女孩。他说：“Tu [脏话] [脏话] conmigo? Yo compro.” 意思是，跟他发生性关系，他会买单。
I got quite angry about it. And I wanted to go after them. But Milades was keeping me from doing that.
我很生气。我想追上去。但米拉德斯阻止了我。
It's a problem of policy in the country. Every person thinks, when they see a girl with a foreigner, that she's a prostitute.
这是国家政策问题。每当人们看到一个女孩和外国人在一起，都认为她是妓女。
The effect of the United States embargo in Cuba on people's daily life, it's hard at the moment. It's very hard. Of course, income is very low. And sometimes, people don't have to eat for one or more days.
美国对古巴的禁运对人们日常生活的影响，目前很困难。非常困难。当然，收入很低。有时，人们一两天没东西吃。
Girls, young girls, there are many who already have kids. And they don't have anything to give them for dinner. They use their body to earn money.
女孩子，年轻女孩，有很多已经有了孩子。她们没东西给她们当晚餐。她们利用自己的身体来赚钱。
At the university, when I started my relation with Leon, everybody knew about it. My classmates were saying that I shouldn't keep that relation, because people were saying that I was a prostitute, just because I had a relation with a foreigner. And then they changed towards me. It was like if I became someone else. It was like if I was betraying my country.
在大学里，当我开始和莱昂交往时，每个人都知道。我的同学说我不应该维持这段关系，因为人们说我是妓女，就因为我和一个外国人有关系。然后他们对我的态度就变了。就好像我变成了另一个人。就好像我在背叛我的国家。
I stayed there 'til the 29th of December. I was there two weeks. I still have the flight ticket. And as the plane left, I had problems to keep my eyes dry.
我待到12月29日。我在那里待了两周。机票我至今还留着。当飞机起飞时，我很难让自己的眼睛不湿润。
These are words to the song, "Don't Leave Me Alone Again."
这是歌词，“别再让我孤单”。
"If you knew how I suffer when you go away from me, if you knew how I only live thinking of you, you'd come back to me, my dear love, mi amor querida."
“如果你知道当你离开我时我有多痛苦，如果你知道我活着只是为了想你，你就会回到我身边，我的爱人。”
At that time, there was no light. It was a very dark period of my life. And I couldn't stand to my promises that I would be there in February. Then I extended the promise to, I think, May. And every time, yeah, I will be there. But every time, I had to excuse again because income was not that way that I could leave just like that.
那时候，没有光。那是我一生中最黑暗的时期。我没能坚守承诺在二月份过去。然后我把承诺延长到，我想，五月。每一次，是的，我会过去。但每一次，我又不得不找借口，因为收入不足以让我随随便便就离开。
Most tourists who will go to Cuba are quite well-to-do, or have steady jobs with a steady income. And it's hard to explain that you can have many troubles. You have to take care about your company to save it from going under.
大多数去古巴的游客都相当富裕，或者有稳定的工作和收入。很难解释说你会遇到很多麻烦。你必须照顾好你的公司，免得它倒闭。
Incomes were quite low. But I didn't know how to explain it to her. And I felt actually ashamed about it.
收入很低。但我不知道该怎么向她解释。实际上我对此感到羞愧。
I thought many things. I thought maybe he was just a tourist who came here to have fun. I regret what I thought, but I thought that. I didn't have any idea about his life or anything. What I had in mind was a European saying that he couldn't come.
我想了很多。我想也许他只是一个来这里寻开心的游客。我很后悔我那样想，但我确实想过。我对他的生活一无所知。我想的是一个欧洲人说他没法过来。
For me, they didn't have that kind of problems. For me, it was like another world. And I thought, perhaps I am not what he needs.
对我来说，他们没有那种问题。对我来说，那就像另一个世界。我想，也许我不是他所需要的。
But at a certain moment, I felt so miserable. And I didn't know what to write down anymore in my letters excusing myself about not being able to come over to Cuba and to be with her. I was so depressed and so-- I don't know if it's self-pitying or whatever. But I wasn't able to cope completely with the situation. And I didn't want to tell her about that, because I didn't want to make a bad impression. And I felt so miserable that, stupidly enough, I didn't write to her for about three months.
但在某一刻，我感觉自己太可怜了。我不知道在信里还能写些什么来找借口说我没法去古巴和她在一起。我太沮丧了，而且我不知道这是自怜还是别的什么。我完全无法应对这种情况。我不想告诉她，因为我不想留下坏印象。我感觉太可怜了，愚蠢的是，我有大约三个月没写信给她。
I said in my house, I don't want to listen to his name again. I don't want anything that has to do with him. I'm too young to suffer this way. I want to forget him.
我在家里说，我不想再听到他的名字。我不想和任何与他有关的事物沾边。我太年轻了，不该这样受折磨。我想忘记他。
"December 19, 1996. Dear Leon, hearing from you was a big surprise for me. To tell you the truth, I thought you would never write again. Indeed, there have been no change in my feelings, although I had decided not to write to you again and to forget about our relation, because I have already cried too much because you do not write.
“1996年12月19日。亲爱的莱昂，听到你的消息对我来说是一个巨大的惊喜。老实说，我以为你永远不会再写信了。确实，我的感情没有任何改变，虽然我已决定不再写信给你，忘记我们的关系，因为我已经因为你不再写信而哭得太多了。”
"I, too, have tried not to think too much of you. But I fail because my heart was stronger and would ride over my soul."
“我也试过不要太想你。但我失败了，因为我的心更强大，它会越过我的灵魂。”
"Do you think you are the only one who have problems? I have people saying whatever they want about me. I have even to stand them saying that I am a stupid bitch because I still think of you."
“你认为你是唯一有困难的人吗？有人对我指指点点。我甚至不得不忍受他们说我是个愚蠢的婊子，因为我还在想你。”
"I have not been able to sleep yet because of a painful, guilty conscience. What a terrible time you have had because of me."
“我到现在还没能睡觉，因为良心不安而充满罪恶感。因为我，你经历了多么可怕的时光啊。”
"Remember that love is like a plant that needs to be watered every day. Lots of luck and happiness, and I suggest you to cheer up. This is not the end of life. Milades. If you think of coming before April, let me know it beforehand."
“记住，爱情就像一株需要每天浇水的植物。祝你好运和快乐，我建议你振作起来。这不是生命的终点。米拉德斯。如果你考虑在四月之前过来，请提前通知我。”
"My dearest, dearest [UNINTELLIGIBLE]." He's so sweet.
“我最最亲爱的……”他太贴心了。
"I miss so much your mouth, your words, your kisses, your big hands. And in effect, I miss you all."
“我好想念你的嘴，你的话语，你的吻，你的大手。实际上，我思念你的一切。”
It's crazy. He even wrote from the plane.
这太疯狂了。他甚至从飞机上写信过来。
"Honey, you can tell to your mother that I'm loving you more than before."
“亲爱的，你可以告诉你的妈妈，我比以前更爱你了。”
"I'll kiss you in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] hours. I'll love you forever."
“我会在几小时后亲吻你。我会永远爱你。”
I already decided to ask Milades to become my wife the first time I saw her. But I didn't do so until I thought time was right for it.
我第一次见到米拉德斯时就决定让她成为我的妻子。但我直到我认为时机成熟时才这么做。
We were walking around the city. It was afternoon. We decided to sit down in Parque San Jose. We were drinking Bavaria, a Dutch beer.
我们在城里到处走。那是下午。我们决定坐在圣何塞公园。我们在喝巴伐利亚啤酒，一种荷兰啤酒。
And we were just talking. At a certain moment, I said to her, "What would you think about the idea to be my wife?" And she said--
我们就在聊天。在某一刻，我对她说：“你觉得做我的妻子这个主意怎么样？”她说——
Of course. I want to marry you. And I asked him, "Can you say it again? Can you ask again?"
当然。我想嫁给你。我问他：“你能再说一遍吗？你能再求一次婚吗？”
And so I repeated my question. I said, "Do you want to become my wife and live with me?" After she got back her breath, she said yes and started crying. So I had to wait again for the rest of the answer. But I can tell that it was very encouraging what happened.
于是我重复了我的问题。我说：“你愿意成为我的妻子，和我一起生活吗？”在她恢复呼吸后，她说是并开始哭泣。所以我不得不再次等待剩下的回答。但我可以说，发生的事情非常令人鼓舞。
And we kissed. I was living in a cloud. We were both, together, living in a cloud.
然后我们接吻了。我生活在云端。我们两人都在云端生活。
That is impossible. Holland is not an immigration country.
这不可能。荷兰不是移民国家。
I invited her to come here in March last year.
我邀请她去年三月到这里来。
That is impossible.
这不可能。
70%--
70%——
If you don't have enough income--
如果你没有足够的收入——
The request was denied by the authorities. With the Cuban government, it's no problem. She has the permissions which she needs to leave the country. But here in Holland-- in fact, in Europe-- it's getting harder and harder every day to have permits for strangers who want to come in to the fortress of Europe.
当局拒绝了请求。如果是古巴政府，没问题。她拥有离开该国所需的许可。但在荷兰——实际上是在欧洲——想要进入欧洲堡垒的陌生人获得许可正变得越来越困难。
My name is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I am second secretary in the Netherlands embassy here in Havana, Cuba.
我叫M·O·约翰逊。我是荷兰驻古巴哈瓦那大使馆的二等秘书。
I am [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And I am working at the Dutch Immigration Board. Well, in the Netherlands we have a restrictive admittance policy because we are just a small country. We don't have a lot of space and not enough jobs. And that's why we are carrying out a restrictive policy. So we just look at the rules, and whether they are in love is not really a criterion.
我是[名字]。我在荷兰移民局工作。嗯，在荷兰，我们有严格的入境政策，因为我们只是一个小国。我们没有太多空间，也没有足够的工作岗位。这就是为什么我们执行严格的政策。所以我们只看规则，至于他们是否相爱，并不是真正的标准。
Anyway, you can invite a Cuban person to the Netherlands if you comply with the requirements of the Dutch authorities. It only costs you a lot of money.
总之，如果你符合荷兰当局的要求，你可以邀请古巴人到荷兰。这只是要花很多钱。
The problem which I have to ask the authorities is that I can't show them on paper that I have a basic income. When you are in love, you don't think about politics. You think just like humans, without any borders, without authorities, because actually, every political system means a prison for people. And for Milades in Cuba, she had a lot of problems because she couldn't get any job. And, well, she has been feeling quite miserable.
我必须向当局提出的问题是，我无法在文件上证明我有基本收入。当你恋爱时，你不会考虑政治。你只是像人类一样思考，没有国界，没有当局，因为实际上，任何政治体制对人们来说都意味着一座监狱。对于在古巴的米拉德斯来说，她遇到了很多问题，因为她找不到任何工作。嗯，她一直感觉相当可怜。
Here, there are rules. To work in certain places, you cannot have any kind of relation with foreigners. I would like to work at the airport, for example, guide in foreigners. And that's something I applied to do.
在这里，有规定。在某些地方工作，你不能和外国人有任何关系。例如，我想在机场工作，给外国人当导游。那是我想做的事。
And I could do it. I have many classmates who have gone to the airport to work. And they are there. But if they find out I am with a foreigner, I cannot be there. It as if we become something dangerous.
我可以做。我有很多同学都去机场工作了。他们都在那儿。但如果他们发现我和一个外国人在一起，我就没法待在那儿。就好像我们变成了危险的东西。
This was a present from him. He brought it in December, when he came. It's a music box with the shape of an organ. It's a nice present. I keep it with love. And the tune, it's "Tulips from Amsterdam."
这是他送的礼物。他十二月过来时带来的。这是一个风琴形状的音乐盒。这是一个很好的礼物。我带着爱保留着它。曲子是《阿姆斯特丹的郁金香》。
[MUSIC - "TULIPS FROM AMSTERDAM" ON MUSIC BOX]
[音乐 - 音乐盒版《阿姆斯特丹的郁金香》]
I love him. He is everything to me. And I know he loves me. I miss him a lot, every day, every minute, every second.
我爱他。他是我的一切。我知道他爱我。我非常想念他，每天，每分钟，每秒钟。
And I will be patient now. We will wait. And we will be together. I hope it's soon.
我现在会保持耐心。我们会等待。我们会在一起的。希望很快。
[MUSIC - "I'LL BE HOME" BY THE FLAMINGOS]
[音乐 - 火烈鸟乐队的《我会回家》]
Act Three, Who Deserves What. The story of The Arabian Nights is actually 350 or 400 stories, depending on how you count them. Many of the stories are stories of impossible love, including the very last story in the whole epic tale, the story of Jasmine and Almond. Mary Zimmerman is the Chicago director who adapted The Arabian Nights for the stage.
第三幕，谁配得到什么。《一千零一夜》的故事实际上是350或400个故事，取决于你怎么算。其中许多故事都是不可能的爱情故事，包括整个史诗般的传说中的最后一个故事，茉莉与杏仁的故事。玛丽·齐默尔曼是一位改编《一千零一夜》舞台剧的芝加哥导演。
There are two lovers who meet in a dream, actually. The girl has a dream of someone. And at the same time, a prince in a faraway place-- he gives some milk to a dervish who asks him for some milk from a cow he's tending. And in gratitude for this, he describes this beautiful woman who's perfect for him, who happens to be the woman who had a dream of him.
有两个人在梦中相遇。女孩梦见了一个人。同时，远方的一位王子——他给一位向他讨要牛奶的托钵僧提供了一些奶牛产的奶。出于感激，王子向他描述了这位完美的女性，她正是那个梦见他的人。
So he goes to the other kingdom. He wanders around. He's sort of in disguise. He sort of looks like a shepherd, because he's actually out of his mind with grief, because he can't find her. He's afraid he won't find her.
于是他去了另一个王国。他在那里徘徊。他有点伪装。他看起来像个牧羊人，因为他悲痛欲绝，找不到她。他担心自己找不到她。
She similarly has fallen ill. And all the doctors in the kingdom are coming in, trying to cure her. But nothing will help, and she won't say what the matter is.
她同样病倒了。王国里所有的医生都来了，试图治愈她。但什么都没用，她也不说出了什么事。
And then one day, her maid comes to her and says, "There's a shepherd outside at our gates, and he looks like--" and he proceeds to describe him, which is exactly as how he appeared in her dream. And so she runs to her father, who she's never asked anything from before, and begs him to hire this particular shepherd. And he does. And so things come about, they go about.
有一天，她的女仆来到她身边说：“门外有个牧羊人，他看起来像——”她开始描述他，完全符合她在梦中看到的样子。于是她跑到从未要求过什么的父亲那里，恳求他雇佣这个特殊的牧羊人。他照做了。事情就是这样发生的。
Now so far, it seems like we're heading on our way to a very happy story.
到目前为止，看起来我们正朝着一个非常幸福的故事发展。
Yeah, but things get in the way. For one thing, he's disguised as a shepherd. And she's a princess. So there's a conflict already there.
是的，但事情总有阻碍。一方面，他伪装成牧羊人。而她是一位公主。所以那里已经有了冲突。
She's supposed to stay behind the curtain of the harem, which she doesn't do. And so one day, she decides to take lunch to him. She pretends she's just taking lunch to all the shepherds, but she serves it on silver dishes.
她本应待在后宫的帘子后面，但她没这么做。所以有一天，她决定给他送午餐。她假装只是给所有牧羊人送午餐，但她是用银盘子送的。
And her uncle sees this, her calamitous uncle, who's so full of hatred of the world that all he wants to do is ruin everyone's happiness. And he always stops musicians from playing and stops people from being together, whatever else he can do, because he's so miserable himself. So he runs straight away to his brother, the father, and tells him about this.
她的叔叔看见了，那个灾星叔叔，他内心充满了对世界的仇恨，只想毁掉每个人的幸福。他总是阻止音乐家演奏，阻止人们在一起，因为他自己太可怜了。于是他径直跑去找他的兄弟，也就是她的父亲，告了密。
And the girl gets into a world of trouble. And she's sent behind the curtain of the harem again. And so they're going to actually marry her off to the son of the calamitous uncle, actually. So I will read it.
女孩惹上了大麻烦。她又被送回了后宫帘子后面。实际上他们要将她嫁给那个灾星叔叔的儿子。所以我来读一下。
"The desolate Almond, who had been clothed against her will in splendid robes and the gold ornaments of marriage, sat on an elegant couch of gold brocade, a flower upon a bed of flowers, silent as a lily, motionless as an idol. She seemed as one dead among the living. But Jasmine, who had come with the other servants to the bridal of his mistress, gave her hope to drink from a single glance of his eyes. Surely the looks of lovers can say 20 things.
“孤独的杏仁，被迫穿上了华丽的长袍和金色的结婚饰物，坐在优雅的金色锦缎沙发上，像花床上的花，像百合一样沉默，像偶像一样一动不动。她在活人中如同死者。但茉莉，和其他仆人一起来参加女主人的婚礼，用一眼就给了她希望。恋人的眼神确实能胜过千言万语。”
When night came, and the princess had been led to the marriage chamber, destiny turned a fortunate face to the lovers. Taking advantage of the little moment before her bridegroom should come to her, Almond glided from the chamber in her gold robes and fled to Jasmine. These two delightful children took hands and vanished, more lightly than the dew-wet breeze of morning.
“当夜幕降临，公主被带进婚房后，命运向恋人们展示了幸运的一面。杏仁抓住了新郎到来前的一点空档，身着金袍溜出房间，奔向茉莉。这两个快乐的孩子携手消失了，比清晨湿润的微风还要轻盈。”
Nothing has since been heard of them or their abiding place. There are few upon this earth worthy of happiness, worthy to take the road which leads to happiness, worthy to draw near the house of happiness.
“此后人们再没听到过关于他们的消息，也没人知道他们的住所。这世上值得拥有幸福的人太少，值得走上通往幸福之路的人太少，值得靠近幸福之屋的人太少。”
Mary, what do you make of the fact that there's this long, long plot that goes for pages and pages and pages, and then suddenly, they get to this moment. And rather than invent something to happen, the narrator just has them vanish, just suddenly, poof, you know?
玛丽，对于这个篇幅极其长、持续了无数页的剧情，然后突然到达这一刻，Narrator没有发明什么情节，而是让他们突然消失——就这么突然，砰的一声，你怎么看？
I guess it maybe demonstrates a kind of faith in the possibility of miracle, or the possibility that there is, in fact, destiny in who you love. And that that place that we're always torn between-- is this a random event that I've met this person? Or this is actually the person where it's written somewhere or told somewhere, in this case, is the other part of myself? The ending of this story really manifests that longing that it is divine and that there is destiny.
我想它也许展示了一种对奇迹可能性的信仰，或者实际上爱情中是有命运的。那种我们总是纠结的地方——我和这个人相遇是一个随机事件吗？还是说这实际上是某处写好的，或者某处述说的，在这个案例里，就是我的另一半？这个故事的结尾确实彰显了那种渴望，即它是神圣的，且命运确实存在。
Mary Zimmerman teaches at Northwestern University. And let's close out this program with a moment from another story in The Arabian Nights, Aziz and Aziza, another story of impossible love. He stands her up on their wedding day. After that, in her love for him, she helps him scheme to get another woman. And then she dies for her love, dying with a poem.
玛丽·齐默尔曼在西北大学任教。让我们用《一千零一夜》中另一个关于不可能爱情的故事——阿齐兹与阿齐扎——的一个片段来结束今天的节目。他本应在婚礼当天出现，却爽约了。在那之后，出于对他的爱，她帮助他策划去追另一个女人。然后她为爱而死，死前留下一首诗。
She says things like, "Your careless head upon my heart lay nesting and dreamed another woman while I wept. So dig my grave deep, and put these words above-- she fears not death, for she has known love."
她说：“你粗心的头靠在我的心窝，梦着别的女人，而我却在哭泣。所以把我的坟墓挖得深些，在这行字下写上——她不惧死亡，因为她已拥有爱。”
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, Nancy Updike, and me. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Sylvia Lemus, and Todd Bachmann.
好吧，今天的节目由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔、朱莉·斯奈德、南希·厄普代克和我制作。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作助理：豪尔赫·贾斯特、西尔维娅·莱姆斯和托德·巴赫曼。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Our story, Mucho Corazon, was produced by Chris Brookes and Michelle Ernsting for the World Views series of first-person narratives from Homeland Productions. The editor was Sandy Tolan. It was produced with funds from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and Radio Netherlands.
我们的故事《深情厚谊》，由克里斯·布鲁克斯和米歇尔·恩斯汀为国土制作公司的《世界观》第一人称叙述系列制作。编辑是桑迪·托兰。节目由公共广播公司和荷兰广播电台资助制作。
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的录音带，请拨打芝加哥WBEZ电台电话312-832-3380。或者你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。《这美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes managing our show this way.
WBEZ的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚，他这样描述我们节目的管理方式。
The intensity of the relationship and the intensity of the feelings is far beyond anything that we've ever experienced before.
这种关系的强度和情感的强度远远超过我们以前经历过的任何事情。
I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
They never let him out of the building to come to the visitation area.
他们从未让他离开大楼去探视区。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
下周回来收听更多《这美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。